я не можу собі дозволити е-е не бути там
і не розділяти хоча б частково цю
небезпеку і це відчуття от постійно
фронту з тими хто там постійно зі всіма
фактами корупції які є потрібно нещадно
боротися і не можна закривати на не хоче
навіть під час війни і не всім потрібно
і не всі можуть тримати зброю в руках
іти на фронт Чи підтримуєте ви
байкетування російської культури Тут все
дуже просто на війні світ чорно-білий на
війні не буває
поза без відчуття добра без Відчуття
того що
попереду перемога що попереду весна ну
будь-яка людина може зійти з може з
божеволіти
Сьогодні ми говоримо зі Святославом
Вакарчуком українські музикантом
громадським діячем і волонтером пане
Святослава Дякую що погодилися на
розмову Дякую вам ми до останнього
узгоджували дату цієї зустрічі адже ви
були на фронті і буквально днями
повернулися розкажіть Де ви були і з
якими враженнями повернулися звідти
деякі не було якщо вже так відверто
говорити як часто буваю з різних
місіями в основному зрозуміло такою
гуманітарною творчою але буває деколи і
щось возим і потрошки
навіть не знає як вам сказати Де я був
зараз тому що з того часу коли ми
домовлялися вже мабуть двічі був на
фронті от в останній раз це було
Скажімо так в районі бахмута і невеличкі
там містечка навколо от я зустрі як
завжди просто
представниками різних бригад цього разу
це були Нацгвардія і дві інші бригади
які в тому в тому місці знаходяться на
Україна є світ зараз щодня читають
повідомлення про запеклі бої під
бахмутом розкажіть вашими очима що зараз
там відбувається там відбувається жах
тому що місто
фактично зруйнована Я добре пам'ятаю як
ми приїхали в це місто
в квітні вперше На початку квітня тоді
це була відносно Мирна територія якщо
можна так сказати Я ніколи не забуду що
ми там сиділи в крафтові пивоварні яка
працювала і значить там Ну мало чим
відрізнялося
принаймні всередині цього закладу
вражені від того як воно було в мирні
часи наприклад в Києві або у Львові або
в інших місцях весною в бахмуті вже було
тихо
в сенсі з точки зору життя людей але ще
відносно
спокійно це вже був Форпост перед
лисичанськом і северодонецьком ми їздили
тоді останні Лисичанськ який потім на
жаль був
росіянами захоплений
от а вже починаючи з літа коли я
приїжджав через Бахмут в інші місця
часів яр там невеличкі весела де
знаходились наші хлопці і дівчата
вислуховування то вже було видно що
місто серйозно потерпає від
обстрілів і від бойових дій однак воно
ще зберігало ознаки життя коли я там був
восени то в центр вже був дуже сильно
пошкоджений А коли я був там зараз то я
такою великою контрасту вони бачив
жодного разу між приїздом і фактично
місто зруйноване От і в ньому
мало дуже життя окрім військових яких
там насправді на той момент було дуже
багато
єдине що контрастувалось з цими
контрастує На в'їзді Бахмут все одно
люди які там залишаються їх небагато але
Вони залишаються умудряються створювати
якісь
аналог життя і мене вразило те що під ці
всі сканувати обстріли бо вони постійно
йдуть безперервно та фактично не може
спокійно по місту пересуватися Але тим
не менше на окраїнах значить
буквально в прямому сенсі слова на
бордюрах значить місцеві жителі створили
такий Базар чи ярмарок і вони там щось
продавали щось ну це якось ну це мені
запам'яталось може найбільше з того
всього з тої поїздки тому що це такі
контраст з
буквальному сенсі воєнним настроєм який
навколо відбувається все-таки ці люди
там продовжують бути
понад усе розкажіть в якому стані зараз
українські захисники чи виснажені вони
безумовно вони фізично втомлені І багато
хто з них замовник психологічно
втомлений але я не можу сказати що за
цей рік Я
помітив якусь таку
[музика]
прогресуючу в тому мені здається що
все-таки ми всі
навчилися з цим жити і воїни наскільки
це можливо теж навчились з цим жити що
дуже важливо Важливо щоб командири А ну
відповідно вище командування дуже
ретельно відслідковувало кому потрібно
відновлення якого потрібно відправляти
на відпочинок тому що
відновлені солдата як правило дуже знов
стають боєздатні в них працює цей
рефлекс що вони ну можуть повернутися на
фронт до своїх побратимів але їм треба
морально і фізично відпочивати якщо ти
безперерви знаходишся В окопах під
джерелами і на виконанні бойових задач
місяцями то безумовно твоя боєздатність
знижується і Це очевидно тому потрібні
ці ротації вони відбуваються
Можливо якби
деколи більш повільно ніж хотілось би
але ну я об'єктивні обставини і тут вже
це все вирішування вирішувати
командування А чим живуть поміж боями
українські військові про що говорять
можливо Про що говорили з вами моя
родина
політика фактично ні от було пару разів
принаймні зі мною це не обговорювати не
цікаво Тим більше що я
стараюсь сам Ну такі теми не підіймати
тому що Вважаю що ну на фронті дуже
важлива єдність особливо на розмова про
політику в українців завжди викликають
суперечки це в нас традиційно тому краще
про це на фронті якщо нема нагальної
потреби не не згадувати але в основному
це сім'я якісь побутові речі часом гумор
е-е
обстановка на фронті вони дуже з радістю
діляться тим чи можуть те що дозволено з
точки зору оголошення інформації
діляться з тим що відбувається навколо
як вони воюють Їм Вони пишаються своїми
здобутками Ну і ми з ними поруч теж
пишаємося з цими здобутками А чи
обговорювали там скандали корупційні
нещодавні зокрема Міноборони Я особисто
не обговорювала я знаю що обговорюють і
це
це безумовно такі скандали вони не
зміцнюють Скажімо так на ній наше
суспільство Ні Нашу армію але мушу
сказати що з того що я бачив хлопці і
дівчата сконцентровані на боротьбі і я
би не помітив Ну скажімо так такої
небезпеки що значить це раптом викличе
якусь
демотивацію Ні я думаю що велика мета
перемога для кожного
солдатів з бійців з офіцерів вона є
основоположною і мені здається що ми вже
помудрішали і не навіть на важливі і Я
би сказав
болючі речі але яким менш важливі ніж
перемога ми вже не відволікаємось так А
як ви особисто відреагували на цей
скандал
як я відреагував Як і всі люди з
тривогують тому що
якщо такі факти є то значить не все
ідеально не все гаразд Разом з тим Я за
8 років війни стаю прихильником і став
прихильником того що
дуже важливо зараз в першу чергу
пам'ятати знову-таки що наша найбільша
мета - це перемога на фронті зі всіма
фактами корупції які є потрібно нещадно
боротися і не можна закривати не хоче
навіть під час війни але категорично
неприпустимо політизувати їх тому що
політизація будь-якого питання а тим
більше такого чутливого як боротьба з
корупцією просто негативно впливатиме на
нашу оборонуздатність А це
непросте завдання просте задача це
задача і керівництво країни це задача і
правоохоронних органів тих які
розслідуються справи це задача
активістів і громадських діячів які і
журналістів які підіймаються питання І
це задача в нас як суспільство Ми всі
маємо бути
дорослими це означає ні на що не
закривати очі бути пильними бути
відповідальними і кожному кожен кожен з
нас мусить розуміти наслідок кож
стратегії Ну але знову таки ніяким чином
це не змінюємо того факту що
корупція під час війни особливо в таких
чутливих і в таких Ну я би сказав святих
питаннях як оборона вона є Ну це кричущі
Злочини з ним безумовно треба дуже різко
боротися роз
відка стоп на Донеччині ви тільки звідти
Розкажіть будь ласка чи є там передчуття
цього прогнозованого наступу А цей
наступ відбувається постійно просто
можливо його масштаб десь більше десь
менше а я не пам'ятаю коли
російський артилерія російські танки чи
російські міномети затихали на Східному
чи південному фронті Можливо на
південному фронті був період певного
умовного затища але знову-таки для тих
хто В окопах під обстрілами цей теж за
те що Важко назвати а на сході ситуація
була дуже складна це по-моєму президент
сказав що півроку вже продовжується
оборона українцями на
рубежів на бахмутському напрямку і
півроку намагається противник взяти цей
Бахмут тому сказати що раптом
в один день всього стане в 10 раз більше
я не військовий експерт Я не берусь про
це говорити але з моїх спостереже просто
цей тиск російський не припинявся але
українці успішного відбувається
Розкажіть як часто ви зараз буваєте на
фронті
Ну як в міру можливостей Розумієте я
стараюсь по-перше фронт це річ широка і
якби це був один маленький участок
навіть як колись раніше Це було під час
перших 8 років цієї воєнної компанії то
все-таки участок був ну суттєво менший
Да зараз він ну дуже сильно збільшився і
ця ділянка від Харківщини до Херсонщини
Ну ти поки заїде ти не можеш за один
день чи навіть за один тиждень побувати
на всьому фронті це фізично нереально
тому ми стараємось розділяти один раз і
в одне місце третій раз втретє От і так
ну
як виходить Ну та постійно так декілька
раз на місяць
А чому для вас важливо туди їздити Ну
якщо я туди не буду їздити то ніхто не
будете їздити от а потрібно щоб
хлопці Дівчата весь час відчували чийось
присутність Я думаю що по-перше я
показую своїм прикладом іншим
громадським діячам і тим відомим людям
що це потрібно по-друге я Мені здається
якимось чином заспокоюю цих хлопців
дівчат знаєте скільки відео
для їхніх мам дружин з чоловіків
відповідно дітей Я вже записав поруч з
ними де я стараюсь їх впевнити в тому що
все буде добре тому що я справді так
вважаю рано чи пізно Все буде добре От
ну і по-третє
здавалось би ми робимо по Океан Ельзи Ми
робимо багато справ і поза фронтом Ми
дуже багато їздимо на захід і збираємо і
допомоги і в принципі підіймаємо що
називається знання про Україну по всьому
світу здавалось би ну ми робимо
достатньо і благодійних концертів Я
проводжу багато але я не можу собі
дозволити
не бути там і не розділяти хоча б
частково цю небезпеку і це відчуття от
постійного фронту з тими хто там
постійно Я вважаю що це несправедливо
було б от вони там а я ну відносно
спокійному чи відносно захищеному режимі
тому я роблю це тому що не можу не
робити А як ви морально тримаєтесь
Працюючи в такому ритмі Та якось я не
знаю Мені вдається Можливо
на високому адреналіні Можливо на
на цій мотивації Перемоги
є декілька речей які мені допомагають це
безумовно спілкування з моєю родиною
рідко Але часом я можу побачити своїх
дітей свою дружину це дуже допомагає
помагає музика якої я займаюся завжди
навіть коли просто є час пишу Я тут
знайде нещодавно написав музику до
фільму
Франциско фільму який зняв відомий
французький режисер і філософ Бернар
релігій про Україну так і вони
називаються Слава Україні це фільм який
він знімав на фронті і вона Я працював
над музикою цього фільму от зараз
відбулось презентація в Франції я думаю
що найближчими тижнями в Києві а потім
колись я думаю він буде і в Широкому
прокаті такий цікавий важливий фільм для
європейців паралельно Ми там готуємо
якісь нові пісні тобто це теж надихає
плюс спорт регулярний фактично треба
будь-який вільний час коли він є Я
займаюсь спортом тому що це не чистить
голову і тримає в тонусі тебе
гумор
зустрічі з друзями
якісь такі земні Прості речі знаєте
цього року було багато болю в житті
українців але чи були миті щастя для вас
ви казали з друзями бачились гумори якщо
ви маєте на увазі рік ну по-перше це
народження моїй доньки Соломії це мить
величезного щастя вона сильно надихає
по-друге Ну от ці моменти побачення
своїми рідними я перші декілька місяців
без виїзного провів в поїздках на гарячі
точки і не бачу своєї сім'ї потім коли
побачив це було таке знаєте
Велике щастя я скажу таку річ може вона
трошки контрверсійна
і не всі зрозуміють але моменти щастя Ну
по-перше я не вірив перманентне щастя Я
вважаю що перманентне щастя це міф і
вони існує не буває
людей які постійно щасливі Скажімо так я
таким не буваю і Мені здається це
неможливо але бувають моменти щастя рад
заради яких потрібно жити і так під час
війни в цих моментів можливо менше Але
вони є щасливою людина може бути
будь-коли навіть під час війни якщо в
неї для цього відповідно складається
обставини просто потрібно ну плекати цей
момент цього щастя і пам'ятати що воно є
не і це дуже сильно
мотивує тебе тому що Я ж бачу як в
багатьох людей справді опускається руки
справді їм здається що все От ця війна
буде вічно тепер ніколи не буде так як
було раніше в них там зруйновані
долі в прямому сенсі слова зруйноване
життя або нема в когось будинків і так
далі І так далі це страшні страшні драми
а деколи і трагедії коли людей забирають
життя і безумовно про це спокійно чи так
знаєте розважливо злегка говорити не
можна але навіть цим людям я насмілюсь
дати пораду що
знаходьте навіть в весняному промінчику
який пробивається зараз через зиму щастя
тому що без відчуття добра з Відчуття
того що
попереду перемога щоб попереду весна ну
будь-яка людина може зійти з розумом
може з божеволіти потрібно тримати це в
собі спочатку для когось це буде штучно
Спочатку це буде Ну самонавіювання але
рано чи пізно ти вчишся відчувати це і
тобі справді добре
До речі чи є у військових улюблені пісні
серед ваших що їм відгукується може ви
помітили я в основному
якщо чесно не дуже їх питаю тому що я
знаю що коли ти почнеш на таку дискусію
то вона перетвориться ну в дуже довге
обговорення Я знаю що для багатьох
українців пісні Океану Ельзи чи там мої
пісні вони є улюбленими але так само я
прекрасно розумію що можливо є хтось хто
взагалі не є великим фаном я завжди їм
жартую що
коли ви приїжджає що каже Я розумію що
може не всі з вас щасливі що я приїхав
краще прислали якусь дівчинку красиву
щоб співала тут Ну це такі знаєте такі
внутрішні жарти Насправді Я думаю що
всім і мені і їм це дуже потрібно хтось
західний журналістів мені сказав що це
потрібно тому що в цей момент люди
відчувають себе частиною українського
культури України що коли вони чують
українські пісні українською мовою ті
які вони знають навіть ті які вони не
дуже знають Вони асоціюють себе частиною
цієї великої культури і це Ну мотивує ще
більше на на захід культури країни землі
от е-е
пісні які я завжди виконується наприклад
Все буде добре або
Еверест або пісня Місто Марії про
Маріуполь це в основному такі мотивуючі
пісні які дають певні меседжі які дуже
потрібно на фронті дуже простими словами
все от так все буде добре або
ми йдем вперед або
буде довіку стояти місто Марії поки
нашими сонце стає і так далі І так далі
Тобто це такі трошки меседжі а лірики на
фронті я співаю трохи менше але буває
дуже люблю співати народні пісні бо вони
відгукуються всім часом співаю Обійми
так не знаю трошки можливо більш
бардівська така такий виступ оскільки я
сам там під гітару там менше музики
більше слів більше тексту як Війна
змінила ваше творчість я не думаю що
вона змінила творчість
Я думаю що вона швидше змінила якийсь
пріоритети і ми там думаємо про ті пісні
які ми хочемо випускати вже не тільки з
точки зору виключно мистецької творчої
цінності який як була раніше а зараз ти
дуже уважно думаєш Ну який посил ти
хотів би дати Зараз людям тобто
випускати якусь
декадентську музику зараз мабуть Я б не
став тому що
Ну тому що
зрозуміло чому можна навіть не
пояснювати
от але але воно все одно пишеться і все
одно ти читаєш і
відчуваєш і Бачиш не тільки чорно-білу
війну але й багато різних відтінків
життя приватного особистого духовного
мистецького
коли я
[музика]
маю дуже рідкі це фактично майже ніколи
не буває але все-таки коли буває Ти
зараз за кордоном в турі маєш там півдня
вільного переїзді між різними містами от
в цей час Я завжди стараюся тим музей і
дивитись на мистецтво на картини тому що
це дуже сильно надихає от я просто там
медитую це мені отдає цю енергію картини
якісь життя з
Скажімо так відчуття мирного життя
я не як і більшість українців не можу
собі дозволити окинутись в нього надовго
але коли в мене є така можливість я
стараюсь взяти звідти скільки можна тому
що це та така
такий міцний
шнур чи як би сказати такий канат який
тримає тебе в реальності як і органічно
звучить ти йдеш дивитися на мистецтво
який є нереальним Ну для того щоб
триматися в реальності та реальність яка
є навколо нас вона часто тебе наприклад
навпаки заводить в тере реальність окрім
виступів на фронті ви виступаєте за
кордоном Розкажіть на сьогодні що вам
ближче Я навіть не буду тут Довго думати
безумовно виступи на фронті набагато
більше ще мливі і я їх вважаю набагато
більш
важливими для себе як для людини як для
особистості як для громадянина і тут
навіть не може бути сумнівів Однак я
думаю що виступи за кордоном Океана
Ельзи зараз я дуже ефективні тому що
по-перше вони готують українців там яких
я дуже багато і яким теж потрібно
морально підтримка і так їм важко і так
їм не просто було покинути не знаю своїх
чоловіків чи жінкам з дітьми переїхати
зовсім інші місця зовсім іншу ситуацію
вони Вони теж в стресій в тривозі їх
мільйони людей і це наші скажімо
громадяни які теж потребують підтримки
Не всі не всім потрібно і не всі можуть
тримати зброю в руках іти на фронт є
зовсім інші ситуації А є маленькі діти є
хвороби є
різні обставини в кожного і ті хто
виїхали вони насправді всією душею
підтримують Україну і і матеріально хто
як може і так далі І так далі Тому їм
теж потрібно підтримка друге - це
зрозуміло так кількість посильної
матеріальної допомо яку ми збираємо я не
ну не оцінюєш занадто пафосно те що ми
робимо але все-таки це десятки мільйонів
гривень і це ну
достатньо багато Я думаю що
на Скажімо так на цю річницю якщо
порахувати то це вже ну дуже-дуже велика
допомога яку ми зробили От ми по-третє і
можливо це найважливіше Я думаю що це
звідси може мало видно з України але це
постійно піднімання українського питання
для
європейців і для людей на заході чи там
в інших країнах тому що це і інтерв'ю це
і зйомки це є велика кількість тисячі
місцевих а жителів які раніше до України
не мали ніякого відношення які приходять
Що наприклад от в Празі на концерті
десятитисячному залі в нас було Ну я
думаю половина як мінімум людей
Чехів або просто жителів Праги які
ніколи не мали до
пострадянського світу жодного відношення
вони пішли підтримати Україну ти мусиш
їм щось сказати Ти можеш дати теж їм
енергію надихнути їх А це все велика
робота Я думаю що вона дуже ефективна і
треба продовжувати робити тому що війна
на жаль ще далеко від закінчення А нам
потрібно ну цей бензин чи там вогонь
Точніше як скажемо багаття постійно
підтримувати А ви сказали про те що в
Празі прийшло багато місцевих скрізь
проходить просто в Празі Це було дуже
дуже явно видно
є концерти у вас є в Німеччині розкажіть
чи стали приходити саме німці більше Ну
дивіться майданчики на яких ви
виступаємо ця Арени на
4-5-7 тисяч людей Тобто це такі зали в
яких ми
до війни виступали
в країнах Східної Європи це означає що
ну великою мірою збільшився інтерес до
України і зму- безумовно Океан Ельзи
це один тільки з проявів але він ну
такий достатньо яскравий насмілюся
нескромно сказати собі от і люди
приходячи на наш концерт вони
підтримують Україну і цим я думаю власне
європейці теж підтримують і німці і
французи і
поляки дуже сильно і та всі країнах в
Ізраїль Ми зараз їдемо другий раз там
повні зали в нас Іспанія в нас вдруге
концерти в Німеччині ви були тричі вже
за цей час зараз поїдемо в Альберт Холл
в Лондоні це цей знаменитий зал в якому
в принципі ще українські артисти не
виступали Для нас це велика честь потім
поїдемо і Дасть Бог якщо все складається
в великі зали Сполучені Штати в Канаду
Тобто це
це потрібно робити і ми з честю це
робимо з гордістю А як ви відчуваєте чи
є у європейців розуміння того через що
зараз проходить український народ
в багатьох є
в багатьох немає але не треба їх старого
за це судити все-таки люди є люди і вони
живуть своїм життям що в більшості
європейців з'явилося це розуміння того
що українська боротьба важлива важлива
для їхнього майбутнього Тобто я не
впевнений що їхній рівень емпатії
настільки високий що вони уявляють і
кожен день думають про про
те як свій день проводить
середньостатистичний українець тут під
обстрілами в тривогах або на лінії
фронту Мабуть ні але і таке є і вони
Волонтери які допомагають Але я думаю що
середньостатистичний європеєць сильно
змінив своє ставлення до України з
індиферентно-байдужого до
підбадьорюючі співчутливе і Я би сказав
таке
вони розуміють важливість України все
більше і більше їх я думаю що якщо
подивитися на це соцопитування ви
побачите що
абсолютно більшість європейців в різних
країнах це може бути від
переважної більшості до абсолютної
більшості підтримують взагалі боротьбу
українців є різні країни де різниця
умовно кажучи відношення до того які має
бути наша перемога і з повагою до них
всіх тут Важливо щоб українці вирішили
якою має бути для них наша для нас наша
перемога і це наше рішення
Як ви гадаєте чи достатньо світ
допомагає Україні особливо зброєю це не
просте питання тому що
інстинктивно зумовлено тобі хоче сказати
Ні недостатньо Вони занадто мало роблять
потрібну більше але давайте будемо
об'єктивними що всі ці 30 років і весь
світ Західний та й український політикум
не так багато робив щоб втекти от подалі
від Росії чи Як казав геть від Москви
Хвильовий тобто були безумовно
патріотично настроєною політику який про
це говорив постійно але й українська
консенсу загальний в українському
суспільстві був такий що А що такого
нічого не буде нам треба дружити тому
зрозуміло ми прогавили час на відміну
балтійців від східної іншої Європи
Україна давно вже мала би бути в НАТО
давно вже мало би бути в Євросоюзі і це
мало бути зусилля всіх політиків
починаючи з 91-го року і до сьогодні
тому коли ми зараз кричимо
що дайте нам більше ми маємо обережно
десь тут спинним мозком пам'ятати що
раніше не кричали так сильно самі а тому
така от непроста іде очевидна ситуація
але це не означає що сьогодні те що там
робить вся країна президент от він
робить великий зусилля зараз він був
європарламенті був от цей турне по за
один день в трьох за два дні в трьох
столицях дуже важливо коли він говорить
абсолютно прості зрозумілі кожна
європейці речі а які Ну достукуються до
серця до душі кожного Це працює і це
оця спілкування ще раз живе спілкування
з європейцями з світом воно потрібне Що
ми маємо зробити Яка Наша задача - це
переконати світ в тому що
ти Скажімо так традиційні дипломатичні
шахові переговори з терористом Росією
неможливі
безумовно із із такими потрібно
розмовляти але не про
Скажімо так не позиційно не так як це
звикли робити
західні лідери багато років а тільки
мова сили і тиску може працювати на
проти Росії тому що ну ви ж бачите що
чим більше їм теж на поступки Тим більше
вони забирають і це абсолютно така
імперська можливо така середньовічна на
ще позиція тобто Таке враження що ця
країна знаходиться десь 500-700 років
назад в історії і тому говорити з ними
мовою
кінця 20 сторіччя абсолютно
безперспективно і це потроху крок за
кроком починає розуміти європейські
політиками і європейські люди не всі
багато ще є питання але більшість так а
чи підтримуєте ви бикутування російської
культури зараз ну дивіться
Тут все дуже просто на війні світ
чорно-білий на війні не буває
поза на війні ти або підтримуєш ворога а
мовчати Це теж мовчазна підтримка ворога
і тоді ти частина ворога і тоді моє
відношення до тебе як до ворога з усіма
витікаючими звідси наслідками і тут не
може бути ніяких компромісів по
відношенню до того що хтось там поза
політикою мистецтво чи спорт тому що
поза політикою не можна бути коли
вбивають людей коли нищить будинки коли
відбувається страшні
акти вандалізму тероризму в тих містах
як Буча чи південь України чи те що було
зроблено з Маріуполем не можна просто
казати я тут не при чому Тому тих тих
хто мовчать А ну і тим більше ті хто
підтримують повинні відповідати за це в
тому числі світовим осудом і як вважаю
його абсолютно справедливим разом з тим
Я Хочу наголосити що велика кількість
Скажімо так
ситуацій Коли ті хто знайшли в собі сили
в Росії не знаю актори музиканти і так
далі виступити прямо проти цього
жаху який відбувається
вони
якби вони собі самі протиставляють Вони
кажуть Ми не є російською державою ми
окремо і вони діють окремо в своєму
окремому ну в світі зараз в своєму
окремому Ну не знаю обмеженому чи
необмеженому їхньому культурному
просторі і це зовсім інша історія якщо
вони щиро бажають Перемоги Україні тоді
ворогами їх ну вважати не потрібно але
всі ці розмови особливо мене мені
обурило коли зараз ну правда мене
фізично обурює той факт що Міжнародний
олімпійський комітет дозволяє собі
моралізаторство дозволяє собі
формалізм юридичної там показуючи
посилаючись на хартії Олімпійські і так
далі ми на питання до них так 36-му році
був був такий Ну скажімо так
неоднозначний факт олімпіади в Берліні
про які ми всі це знаємо але питання
Чому не проводилося Олімпіада в 44-му
році чи в 40-му році чогось чого ж вони
і не проводили вважаючи що спорт поза
політикою сьогодні відбувається фактично
те саме в Європі іде
величезна війна якої не бачив світ
спочатку
405 ну закінчення 45-го року з Другої
світової війни то як ми можемо в
принципі Робити вигляд що цього не
відбувається
Я вважаю що це несправедливо і ну про це
потрібно абсолютно щиро говорити не
потрібно влаштовувати істерик там в
українській стороні потрібно планомірно
працювати над тим щоб спортсмени
продовжує держави не мали права
виступати на Олімпійських іграх
лікуємось
не тому що
якось складається так не до цього зараз
але я ще раз кажу я поважаю позицію тих
хто абсолютно відкрито засудив агресію
Путіна і Росії вони є ці люди ми їх
знаємо і безумовно їхня позиція
заслуговує на повагу
Це просто не на часі Я думаю що зараз не
потрібно давати
жодних жодних інших меседжів крім того
що Україна йде вперед і має перемогти
А що для вас перемога якщо говорити якщо
вам Важливо щоб я сказав по пунктам
словами Я не буду про це говорити тому
що
ні надмірні очікування ні заниження
очікування зараз нікому не потрібні нам
просто треба йти вперед захищати свою
територію Нам треба зробити так щоб
сильно
вільно незалежна європейська Україна
більше ніколи не знала жахів війни і
Вогник ніколи більше несмів на нас
напасти оце для нас важливо Та не
Святослава Дякую вам за цю розмову дякую